so in the last video I introduced this
multivariable chain rule and here I want
to explain a loose intuition for why
it's true why you would expect something
like this to happen so the way you think
about an expression like this you have
this multi variable function f of X Y
and you're plugging things in but just
that function itself you'll be thinking
of taking a two-dimensional space you
know here's our XY plane and then
mapping it to you know just a real
number line and I'll think of this as F
as the output so somehow our whole
function our function takes things from
this two-dimensional space
and plugs it on to this output T you're
thinking of as just another number line
up here so T and then you've got two
separate functions here you know X of T
and Y of T X of T and Y of T each of
which take that same value for a
specific input you know it's not that
they're acting on different inputs X of
some other input T and Y of some other
input it's the same one and then they
move that somewhere to this output space
which itself gets moved over and in this
way you're thinking of it as just a
single variable function that goes from
T and ultimately outputs F it's just
that there's multi-dimensional stuff
happening in between and now if we start
thinking about the derivative of it what
does that mean what does that mean for
the conception of the picture that we
have going on here
well that that bottom part that DT
you're thinking of as a tiny change to T
right so you think of it as kind of a
nut I'll draw it as a sizable line here
for like moving from some original input
over but you might in principle think of
it as a very very tiny nudge in T and
over here you'd say well that's going to
move your intermediary output in the XY
plane to you know maybe it'll move it in
some amount again imagine this is a very
small nudge I'm going to give us some
size here just so I can write into it
and then whatever that nudge in the
output space and it's a nudge in some
direction that's going to correspond to
some change in F some some change based
on you know based on the differential
properties of the multivariable function
itself and if we think about this this
change
might break it into components and say
this shift here has some kind of DX some
kind of shift in the x-direction and
some kind of dy some shift in the
y-direction but you can actually reason
about what they should be because it's
not just an arbitrary change in X or an
arbitrary change in Y it's the one that
was caused by DT so if I go over here I
might say that DX is caused by that DT
and the whole meaning of the derivative
the whole meaning of the single variable
derivative would be that when we take DX
DT this is the factor that tells us you
know a tiny nudge in T how much does
that change the X component and if you
want you could think of this as kind of
cancelling out the DTS and you're just
left with X but really you're saying
there's a tiny nudge in T and that
results in a change in X and this
derivative is what tells you the ratio
between those sizes and similarly
similarly that change in Y here that
change in Y is going to be somehow
proportional to the change in T and that
proportion is given by the derivative of
Y with respect to T that's the whole
point of the derivative with respect to
T and again you can kind of think of it
as as if you're canceling out the T's
and this is why the the fractional
writing this liveness notation is
actually pretty helpful you know people
will say all mathematicians would like
shake their heads at the idea of
treating these like fractions but not
only is it a useful thing to do because
it is a helpful mnemonic it's reflective
of what you're going to do when you make
a very formal argument and I think I'll
do that in one of the following videos
I'll describe this in a very a much more
formal way that's a little bit more
airtight than the kind of hand waving
nudging around but the intuition you get
from just writing this as a fraction is
basically the scaffolding for that
formal argument so it's a it's a fine
thing to do I don't think mathematicians
are shaking their head every time that a
student or a teacher does this but
anyway so this is this is kind of what
gives you what that DX is what that dy
is and then over here if you're saying
how much does that change the ultimate
output of the f you could say well your
nudge
sighs DX over here you're wondering how
much that changes the output of F that's
the meaning of the partial derivative
right if we say we have the partial
derivative with respect to X what that
means is that if you take a tiny nudge
of size X this is giving you the ratio
between that and the ultimate you know
change to the output that you want you
could kind of think of it like this
partial x is cancelling out with that DX
if you wanted or you could just say you
know this is a tiny nudge in X this is
going to result in some change in F I'm
not sure what but the meaning of the
derivative is the ratio between those
two and that's what lets you figure it
out and similarly that's just you might
call this the change in F caused by X
like due to X due to I should say DX but
that's not the only thing changing the
value of F right that's not the only
change happening in the input space you
also have another change in F and this
one I might say is due to dy due to that
tiny shift in Y and what that's going to
be we know it's going to be proportional
to that tiny shift in Y and the
proportionality constant this is the
meaning of the partial derivative that
when you nudge Y in some way it results
in some kind of nudge in F and the ratio
between those two is what the derivative
gives so ultimately if you put this all
together what you'd say is there's two
different things causing an ultimate
change to F so if you put these together
and you want to know what the total
change in F is so I might go over here
and say the total change in F one of
them is caused by partial F partial X
and I can multiply it by DX here but
really we know that DX the change there
was in turn caused by DT so that in turn
is caused by the change in the X
component that was due to DT there was
of course of size DT and then for
similar reasons the other way that this
changes in the in the Y direction is a
partial of F with respect to Y but what
caused that initial shift in Y you'd say
well that was you know
a shift in why that was due to tea and
that size a dy DT times DT you can think
of it so slight nudge in T causes a
change in Y that change in Y causes the
change in F and when you add those two
together that's everything that's going
on that every that's everything that
influences the ultimate change in F so
then if you take this whole expression
and you divide everything out by DT so
you know I kind of erase it from this
side and put it over here DT this is
your multivariable chain rule and of
course I've just written the same thing
again but hopefully this gives a little
bit of an intuition for how you're
composing different nudges and why you
want to think about it that way of
course you can see this and you see that
like the partial F kind of cancels out
with that DX and this partial Y kind of
cancels out with that dy and you're left
with the two different things that
constitute a change in X you know this
one is only partially the change in F
this is also only partially the change
in F but together they give the ultimate
change in F and I think that gives a
very strong reason if you break it down
like that why this should be true